all the discussion the discussion can be
doesn't have to be an hour twenty
twenty-five for him okay
good evening everyone
tonight's symposium is occurring in
association with the Pilate Oh show at
the Morgan and we are delighted to have
here tonight
representatives from the from the Royal
Institute of British Architects who have
sponsor the show the the ones who hold
all the riches of the Palladio drawings
over here the the vault and after I make
a quick set of comments to introduce
tonight's occasion I'm going to have the
director of the library come up and give
a short talk short a couple minutes
description of their efforts over there
and also the chief curator tonight's
occasion is an occasion for
recombination
Manfredo to Forry in his book venison
renaissance claims that Palladio is the
master of the combinatory arts he says
it is in fact undoubted the case that
Palladian architecture displays in ours
cabinet Oriya elaborated within a true
typological laboratory Palladio one is
syntactic freedom through a fill
illogical criticism that was in line
with the best humanist traditions for
Palladio however the classical code was
merely a quote field of variation and
not a handbook of rules
that I would say would be the guiding
quote for tonight a field of variations
not a handbook of rules for the way in
which Palladio can speak to us today in
fact I would say he speaks to us not
just as someone who can combine various
cultural and tectonic artifacts but who
can in fact recombined in a new
recombinant forms that Palladio did as
we'll see tonight and into some new
forms of cultural mutation and that's
the legacy of Claudio that continues
today our first speaker is guido box
Remini and guido bought Remini is in
fact the keeper of the deep flame for
reawakening Palladio he is the director
of the of the Center for Palladio in
Vicenza and and it is through him that
architectural history and his course and
conferences and publications around the
Renaissance and up into the 18th century
into the modern period is being
reawakened in Italy a student of Tafari
in fact and trained in architecture and
history
he believes in Palladio as a living
force not as past as a past frozen
moment our second speaker was supposed
to be Howard burns Howard burns was
described to me by 240 himself in a
lunch one time he said the two pillars
of Renaissance scholarship Howard burns
and Christoph Rummel
unfortunately that pillar suffered some
structural damage to his knee a couple
days ago and
and so cannot be here and consequently
my brief introductory remarks had to be
extended into a presentation I won't say
I will stand in for that pillar I won't
even say I will take his place let's
just say I'll occupy that time slot and
concluding will be will be Peter
Eisenman who is I would have to say the
most significant force in architecture
in the past 50 years through his
architecture his writing he is
organizing his provocations its
publications his teaching he has kept
alive the field of and the discourse of
architecture as as a deep cultural and
intellectual proposition manifest in
physical form it is never far away from
physical form and we'll see that in the
beginning of his works to the present
day if we look at the classic image of
vid cover we see not only a series of
combinations and not only just a
reapportioning and proportioning of the
various villas as they manifest over
time but the possibility that this is in
fact a performative recombination this
these forms of recombinations were not
only evident through the analysis of
someone like vid cover
but as we can see in flutters own work
where a series of studies for the
modernization of the vote a house over
here or or in his studies of the of the
bass over here
all sorts of forms of taking spatial
elements and recombining them you know
into new imaginations of the past in
order to push his own architecture in
the future we'll see from guido bought
Remini pilate owes illustrations for a
series of tactical maneuvers we just saw
some spatial maneuvers of Pilate Oh
we'll see his illustrations of tactical
maneuvers in his illustrations of
various war manuals and if we go back to
1963 and a certain PhD treatise by Peter
Eisenman which was just published a
couple of years ago we'll see that
Pilate Oh appears in fact the building
he's going to talk about tonight Palazzo
karakov T and what is interesting about
what Peter says in his dissertation over
here is that these are fixed facial
units which he opposes to more dynamic
movements spatial units that he analyzes
within his dissertation in fact I think
we'll see today that he finds a much
more dynamic than he thought of them at
that time over here and will show us a
whole series analysis he does say in his
afterwards of this treatise that after
traveling after three months traveling
in Europe that first summer with Colin
Rowe I knew what I wanted to write an
analytic work that related what I had
learned to see from Pilate Oh to Tehran
ye from Raphael to Guido Remini in fact
Pilate Oh proceeds to Rania for
Eisenmann
even in his publication of the Toronto
work over here we see already that the
analysis of these dynamic movements are
already being put into play it's no
coincidence that in that 1973
publication there was also the second
part of the transparency literal and
phenomena from Colin Rowe and Robert
Slutsky which began to look at the
possibility of ambiguous repositioning
on the facade surface but already
Eisenmann was developing an
inside-outside
in series of relations was in fact later
on miss reading the drawing so that in
axonometric could generate a building
and over on the other side over here we
have his final book on Tehran you where
Palladio leads away so Palladio has been
the crew one of the crucial figures even
perhaps more than Tehran yay and we're
going to see that in a work of in a book
that he'll be publishing the next couple
of years of this Palladian studies with
that I will now introduce Erin Murray a
director of the
I'm not going to take much time I just
wanted to take this opportunity to thank
mark Rockatansky for organizing a
symposium in connection with our
exhibition of which my colleague Charles
hind the RIT a curator of drawings and I
are co-creators together with Guido
Bertram Eenie one of the speakers
tonight I thought that since you have
chosen term originally pioneered by
genetics the term recombinant in the
title of tonight's discussion that
perhaps you might be interested in
knowing that the most DNA of Claudio's
that you are likely to find you are
going to find on the drawings that are
kept by the Royal Institute of British
Architects I'm not going to tell the the
whole story but it is a it is a story
that has elements of detective tale and
elements of sort of great cultural
shifts in the 17th and 18th century
Europe the drawings we we have the bulk
of Claudio's drawings that survived some
380 drawings from some 330 sheets it
always makes me very guilty to say that
particularly in the presence of guido
because the trends are so rich in the
actual buildings has ended up with
a few more than 20 drawings and so in
order to study the drawings you you do
need to come to London and the drawings
came to us through two great cultural
figures not just architectural figures
but cultural figures / 17th and 18th
century England
Inigo Jones who went to Italy armed with
a copy of Claudius quattro libri in 1613
and 1614 and brought back some hundred
and fifty party or drawings that mostly
dealt with design issues some hundred
odd years later rich boyle better known
to you perhaps as Lord Burlington
brought back another stash of over 150
drawings and eventually succeeded to
purchase the Jones lot and the lot that
travelled down through the successors to
Jones's it state bringing these 300 odd
sheets together pasting them into
portfolios giving them numbers and
describing them and that really is at
the beginning or really a is a link in
the vast exposure that these drawings
had at least amidst the architectural
profession
in England in the 17th and 18th century
and so when people ask the why of the
prolific influence of Claudio on the
development of Anglo palladianism in
Britain and in fact on the survival of
his ideas albeit in a modified form for
some 400 years that story really goes to
the fact that both Jones his successors
and Burlington and his circle exposed
the drawings to the eyes of others
mostly architects but other people from
their circles and thus carried the
influence in an almost uninterrupted
form forward only 31 of the drawings
that we own are here for the exhibition
at the Morgan which looks at a very
narrow element of narrow but rich
element of Pilate and legacy and that is
the transmission of his ideas through
Anglo palladianism to
America and that is the subject of the
exhibition the exhibition is accompanied
by the by a number of educational events
on different aspects of the exhibition
and I hope that it will not be disloyal
to not be seen as disloyal to this great
institution if I mentioned that on the
8th of May the Harvard Graduate School
of Design in cooperation with the Morgan
and at the Morgan is organizing a full
day symposium called Claudia or J on the
relationship between Palladian ideas and
contemporary practice I've just liked to
hand over the microphone for 2 minutes -
Charles Hein the HJ Heinz curator of
drawings from the RI ba who will mention
some of the salient points of the
exhibition and I wanted to wish you a
very good evening thank you
martien very brief the exhibition is
arranged release that you can look at
the architects mind to see how he looked
to antiquity to the buildings of Rome to
see what they could teach him about
Roman theory and design then it moves on
to sections dealing with how he used the
lessons he learned from antique
buildings in the creation of drawings of
buildings villas and palaces and the
progress of his design for one of his
great Venetian churches the red and
Torre and then the Pilate reception
concludes with a section around the four
books of architecture the book he
published in 1570 which placed in
context his views on architecture and
building from simple elements of the
orders and doors windows and so on and
how you put them together to create
buildings which of course he used as
examples his own buildings and then to
his studies of Roman buildings and
making more accessible
to the intelligent public at whom he is
named in the book and it's through the
book and in due course the presence of
his drawings in English circles in the
17th and 18th century that brings
palladianism to a wider public with the
public and through pattern books in
particular gets published get circulated
in America and we have a total of I
think 65 objects the American section is
dealt with principally through models
but in a morgue until the end of you
live I
before beginning I would like to say
that I am here in New York as a Christ
foundation fellow at Italian Academy at
Columbia and for this I would like to
thank its director David Friedberg and
they would also like to thank Mark
Lockett asking for giving me the
opportunity to speak here tonight
one day in all likelihood around 1574
Andrea Palladio in the company of the
Venetian cavalry general Valerio
kellicotti
commanded a military exercise we know
this from the II witness account by the
historian francesco patrizii in his book
parallel military published in 1595
quote from patrizii the vision teen and
rebel radio an architect by profession
and Valerio key riccati who had never
seen war in our day but books by alien
and Leo and Caesar were able to amaze
those process present they saw the first
disembark the creo and soldiers from a
galley in marvelously good order and
then ii had 500 infantrymen to all the
alien military drills in great ordered
and with ease and I was one of the
spectators the military exercises that's
involved that they disembark on of troop
and their maneuvers on land
Francesco patrizii stresses that the
maneuvers directed by Palladio in
Chillicothe did not reflect the
contemporary practice of warfare but
were entirely inspired by the ancient
treatises such as tactics by alien the
second century AD Greek writer tactics
by Leo the wise who had Byzantine
Emperor and of course Julius Caesar
commentaries on the Gallic Wars in the
1570s
Palladio was probably one of the most
busy architect in Italy so why at the
heads of his career
did he devote his energies to meter it
maneuvers on the battlefield inspired by
the great scholars of what
in the ancient world and how was his
interest in military matters related to
his activities as an architect I will
try to provide some answers to those
questions in this lecture but as an easy
route into a world now very remote from
us
I would like to begin by looking at
these scenes from Spartacus one of the
Stanley Kubrick's great films following
a revolt which said which has set alight
the south of Italy the turning point in
the fate of the slave army led by
Spartacus has can an open battle in the
field against Crassus legions Kubrick's
first lingers over the latest phases
showing us how brave and determined they
are however as the scene progresses and
the organized ranks of the Legion come
down the hills it becomes painfully
obvious that there is an enormous gap
between the generals bravery of the
horde of slaves and the lethal well
organized Roman army having come down
the hills the legions prepares for
battle transforming a chessboard
formation into a combat line our hearts
are with the brave band of slaves but
our minds are inevitably intrigued by
the fascinating logic of the legions
movements I wanted to show you these
scenes because surprising as it may seem
it was precisely this all inspiring
logic and efficiency that Pilate wanted
to reintroduce in the 60 cent revenue
talk through the example of Caesar
sepium and Hannibal our story of
Palladio's interests in military affairs
begin with something he jotted down in
the merging of
of his architectural drawings I am
talking about this small rhombus
constructed by Greek lambaste lambdas
sketched in the margin of the drawing of
the Colosseum's for the fourth 1540s
here Palladio was not practicing writing
the Greek alphabet but he was jotting
down a diagram taken from one of the
books that he had been studying at the
time that book was aliens tactics one of
the key sources of the 16th century
thinking about warfare alien has
preserved the memory of the formation
and strategies of Alexander the greatest
successors and like in 20th century
futurist book the written text was
illustrated with battalions made up of
letters of the alphabet symbolizing the
various type of soldiers on the
battlefield in the printed edition of
alien horsemen are always represented by
the Greek letter lambda and in his quick
sketch Pilates probably reflecting on
the rhombus formation of a squadron of
horsemen which may be ordered in
horizontal vertical or oblique lines
Palladio would have had no difficulty in
finding a copy of alien which had been
available in various print that printed
latent translations since the 15th
century we also know that in the library
of some mark in Venice
there was a 14th century manuscript
exemplar this was a Byzantine codex of
alien which Cardinal bazarian had saved
from the ruins after the fall of
Constantinople in 1453 and eventually
took to Venice in 1468 there are several
reasons for believing Pilar you may have
seen and studied this manuscript
firsthand but there are also other clues
to Palacios interest in military of
in 2008 I was able to publish these two
out autography Palladio drawings which
are actually direct on versa of the same
sheet now in Worcester College Oxford in
this part of the shield
Palladio annotates a passage from
Polybius describing the Roman legion but
the drawing on this sheet do not
illustrate the passage of Polybius they
show two battalions face facing each
other we see from the - on the letter
all symbolizing a spear that the two
battalions are confronting each other
and one battalion assumes a specific
shape in order in order to thwart the
enemy armies offensive this battalion
for example is in a scissors shape to
oppose the attack by this battalion this
is the Caesar and this in the wedge
shape these elements tell us that
Palladio had studied book of military
tactics like this one by Bautista de
Laval we show exactly the same kind of
clash between a battalion of Caesars
formation and a battalion of a wedge
formation - Palladio was utterly a
fashion fascinating by these books of
battle tactics look for example at this
is another diagram of the this shape in
this another look at the diagram from
another book
Giovanni Matteo Ciccone a military
treatise publishing 1577 in Venice with
this fantastic battalion of infantry men
deployed in the diamond shape this or
this infantryman in a triangle formation
or the nine hundred men in rows with
half
formation Battaglia Rosa Luna at this
point we are hardly surprised to find
affinities between the diagram of
military treaties and architectural
drawings by Palladio this like this -
for the temple of Palestrina similarly
we discover that this kind of treaties
inspire ecology for example for some
project of villas like villa but without
apology or in this one of his unusual
villa villa much legal a brand which has
two curvilinear burn burns here in here
on both fronts of the house which is it
clearly derived from the treatise
published 40 years before by the Laval
with this formation with 300 Pike's in
two units you can see his project
exactly from this there is an element in
Palacios studies which I would like to
stress in which Kubrick's film conveys
very clearly that is in these drawings
that is these drawings are studies of
movements are dynamic compositions at
this point we have we have to go back to
one of the seminal books of the
Renaissance warfare
the art of war which niccol machiavelli
published in Florence in 1521 this was
the only book whose whose publication
Machiavelli had been able to oversee
personally in his lifetime
what is this fact important because it
tells us that Machiavelli himself
inserted the seventy figures presented
in the text in the conception obviously
in the conception of his Illustrated
text on war Machiavelli was clearly
inspired by the printed version of alien
by the new features in Mac evilest world
was that the movement
of the troops was represented this is
the first figure figure a prima in
Machiavelli book is actually true images
this is the column of marching soldiers
and these are the same column deployed
ready for battle the column of X are the
corporals at the head of the group of 10
soldiers the O's with dashes are Tariq
men who bear the brunt of the cavalry
charge and behind them each simple small
circle stands for infantrymen with
swords and shields who move into action
after the enemy cavalry has been halted
and the combat between foot soldiers
between begins the change from marching
formation to the battle array to change
the from the march information to the
battle array the segment of the column
each move to the right of the next one
the pikemen thus end up at the front
with the Schwartz and the shields
immediately behind them and the
corporals to the left or to the right of
their groups of ten soldiers the second
figure on the other hand illustrates how
to deploy a marching Cong if an attack
is feared from the left in this case the
first segment of the column is entirely
made by pikemen and the corporals are on
at the head and the rear of every
segment so that when they move to the
right of each other
the pikemen will remain on the right
hand side ready to fend off a cavalry
child charge from that quarter if the
cavalry attacks from the right the
column is arranged in the same way
except that the value segments move
to the left of each other in the third
figure the modern become becomes more
elaborate because the segment of the
column are of different lengths the two
central segments 16 rows each move to
the right of the longer first segment I
consisting of 25 rows and in turn are
flanked on the right by the fourth
segment also 25 rows to create a space
at the front to be occupied by the
artillery or if the first eight rows
move forward to leave a space especially
truly display space for the main square
used by the chariots not how the flanks
are occupied by the pikemen to protect
from cavalry attacks
I have always associated this dynamic
representation of battle with this
drawing in which Pilate is working on a
plan for a Palazzo in the chenza the
palace was never actually built but we
have identified the site at the bottom
of the drawing here
Palladio sets out the measurements of
the Lord as we can see it is a rather
special site since only the right hand
side here adjoins a neighboring house
whereas the other three sides this this
in this freestanding we know this
because there are windows in the wall
you can see here windows in this side in
this side and this side and fireplace
here so only this only by shuffling the
individual elements Palladio drill do
twenty alternatives this is the site of
the building this is the building and by
shuffling the individual elements
Palladio drill 20 alternative idea here
he say ok corridor larger and quarter no
Corey
rectangular atrium no corridor square
atrium scale over scale square scale and
so on
Palladio studies of the roman army is
described by Polybius produce another
very interesting image it is the first
printed image that Palladio ever
prepared the imaging question is the
encampment of the Byzantine general
Belisarius inserted as unique
illustration in the long poem italia
liberated I go to Italy freed from the
gods by John Georgia trissino
Palacios mentor published in 1546
Palladio reconstruction of the Romana
campaign closely follow the descriptions
of the Roman custom provided by Polybius
in book six of the historia as you know
a distinctive feature of the Roman
military encampment was the fact that it
was systematically constructed in the
same way independently of the lay of the
land chosen for the site Polybius
mentions that the Carthaginians on the
opposite choose naturally protected
position such as a hilltop or a bend in
a river and then proceeded to fortify
them
the Carthaginians thus adapted the for
modern campaign to the nature of the
chosen site but the Romans always built
the same camp the same structure
regardless of the land the various
military constructions units worked
according to standardized Percy
procedures very difficult for Italian
and the previously established routine
almost with the almost with their eyes
shut they laid out a grid on which they
to arrange the value stand this is the
the of the general the width of the
streets and internal path the excavation
of ditches this
of open areas and so on as described by
Polybius and reconstructed by Palladio
the roman in campaign was a structure
built in the open field fenced and
crossed by rectilinear access it has a
well-defined here high hierarchy which
culminated in a proto liam the general
quarters surrounded bike is this is the
Praetorian surrounded by a series of
minor quarters and open areas with
specialized functions the pay area the
inner forces and so on it does not take
any great leap of the imagination to see
that this structure is very close to
Pilates villas which are organized
around the owner residence flagged by
minor buildings dedicated to agriculture
works and farm yards with various
functions the interpretation of the
Roman custom as a model for architecture
is something that sebastiano serlio
worked on at around the same time of
Palladio but he eventually transformed
the castrum into a full-blown City but I
have always associated the Roman
encampment with this Palladio drawing
for the rialto bridge in Venice it would
be simplest however to interpret them as
mere bridge designs it will debate it as
a mere bridge designs it actually
envisage a rational organization of the
Rialto area the commercial center of the
city this is one of the very few
surviving drawings by Palladio which
addresses design on an urban scale it
showed the rialto bridge here line
between two places at the end of the
bridge with on the right indication of
the main architectural features in the
mediate vicinity the fondeco de Tedeschi
here and the church of san bartolom
is Palladio considers superimposing the
rational space of two rectangular spaces
on the Europe and cares of in conclusion
we must not SEPA larger studies of the
Roman army as being secondary to the
architectural to his architectural
activities indeed in the 5070 they
become a key part of his research
preoccupations in 1575 he published an
illustrated edition of Julius Caesar
commentaries and on his death in 1580
the illustrated edition of polybius
history was ready to printing in 1575
the been the Venetian publisher Pedro de
Francesca printed the book entitled
commentaries by Caillou Julius Caesar
blahblahblah with copper figures of the
encampment made by Andrea Palladio to
facilitate the readers understanding of
history
Palladio personal applied for the
privilege for the copyright for the
edition in the last month of 1874 this
fact implemented he played an active
role in the overall publishing project
and also he made a joint investment with
the publisher to an Italian translation
published a decade earlier
Palladio added the study on the own the
Roman army as an introduction and 42
actions which were inserted between the
pages of the text he took special care
over linking up the words and images on
the upper left margin of each plate is
one or more letters here you can see of
the alphabet also found at the inch bit
of the text
beside the relevant passage on the back
of it of its aging a legend lists
the key places fetcher in the image and
repeats the page number of the
illustrated pages of the 14 of the 42
plates
5 provides a specific explanation the
Roman in campaign again the the Roman
bridge over the rhine a section of a
french-style walls woven with trunks and
plugged with stones a close-up view of
the double trenches of caesar fortified
capitulation and the deployment of the
legend and the phonics the other the
other 43 plates are all feature but all
featured battles and sieges at times
with several plates in sequence for
instance in this three plates for the
three stages of the siege of Alicia on
the other cases such as the plate on the
Battle of be bracketed freezes active
stages of the battle are set side by
side in the same picture the plates show
Caesar's Legion the Helvetii idea to
link in the body one is the first stage
of the encounter when the Helvetii eye
heart attacks the three Roman legions
followed by the back of the tool engine
boy then we can see the following stage
where the LDT I have fallen back pressed
by the region's widely tool in G and boy
stage three are passed back pushed back
by the legions at another point a short
time prior to his death in 1580 Pilate
was on the point of publishing an
illustrated edition of the histories of
Polybius in particular of the Greek and
Punic Wars
Palladio conceived of the dost rated
polybius as a continuation of the
commentaries on 1575 a second volume of
an ideal Syria the two works share the
same editorial logic with an atlas of
images inserted between the pages of the
tech
in the same effective number of plates
and method of drawing and etch them one
interesting knowledge is found on plate
true which is dedicated to the Roman
quinquereme the reconstruction a unique
document of Palacios interest in the
design of ships follows politics which
carefully describes the car was invented
by the Romans to grapple Carthaginian
ships in the First Punic War and
Palladio States also this Battle of the
Cape ignores the ensuing thirty-nine
illustration are all stills from
Polybius narrative with the 90 with
effectiveness of death of an atlas they
represent the sequence of war events
which led to the Roman conquest of the
Mediterranean Dominion the theatres for
the battle move from Italy to Spain
Greece and Asia Minor
Pelagius readers was thus able to see
the reconstruction of cities that has
been worked or greatly modified by time
like debasing race new cartridge in
Spain or solutes appearing as a mine in
Asia Minor
Palladio chose the bird's-eye view for
all the plates which enables him to
describe the landscape and also to
create compelling images the cities can
be understood in terms of their layout
in geographical context while
description on individual buildings is
only sketchy Pilate examines the sides
with the eyes of a military man taking
into account the autography and the
defensive or offensive potential of each
side rather than with the gaze of a
traveler interested in architecture or
natural beauty spots battles in the
fields account for the majority of the
images the principal subjects are the
deeds of Hannibal in Scipio
this place is one of the true which are
dedicated to the battle of cannon in
show shows the setup of Hannibal and
CEOs army the caption in the letter L
and then state weak soldiers in the
middle flagged by African veterans in
fact
Polybius recounts that Hannibal put the
weaker troops in the central part of the
formation so that under the pressure of
the Roman legions the Carthaginians fell
back attracting the Romans into a pocket
surrounded them and defeated them this
is a modern reconstruction of the
outcome of the battle and this is the
other Palladio clay from which you can
really understand the reliability of
Pelagius reconstruction the same goes
for the Battle of Zama where Scipio sets
up the legions in small groups distanced
from each other in order to create
corridors to allow the Carthaginians
elephants to pass and this is the
Palladio in here you can see the
corridor in this day
Hannibal elephants but what was Palladio
interested in warfare you will will have
no doubt realized that Palladio's plates
never show the clashing of masses armies
and the heroic deeds of the commanders
who are never recognized Abel in the
images in the sense
Pelagius with Palladio sweep of views
have them diametrically opposed to the
painting of Deeds also when we consider
the grandiose painting celebrating
antiquity Palladio time such as this
fantastical total battle of issues a
larger choice of a specific viewpoint
provide the best way of seeing the
deployments of trope in the field in
their ography of the side which is of
crucial importance in winning battles
Palladio shows us the architecture of
the battle his it's geometry almost its
anatomy we may say alluding to the
figures that unravel on you said in the
landscape the famous anatomical this
villages interest for army organization
is only understandable if we link it to
his parallel disinterest in military
architecture
unlike many Renaissance architects from
Francesca Georgia to Michelangelo
Palladio interest in war was not focused
on designing the perfect bastion or the
most effective city walls but primarily
on the organization of the army in the
battlefield he write as much in his
introduction to the addition of Caesar's
commentaries it is impossible I am
quoting from Palladio text it is
impossible that any Citadel or fortress
can hold out and defend against the
onrush and force of a powerful enemies
thus when I consider how to deceive this
enemies and more importantly to defend
kingdoms and cities I feel that nothing
is more suitable for the purpose that
having an excelent and well-ordered army
for this reason Paulo did not show any
great interest in military architecture
but since in his early years spent in
the company of general attritional he
had often studied the deployment of
troops and military maneuvers the
lowest-rated edition of Julius Caesar's
commentaries and policy stories are the
result of almost 40 years interest in
the subject there were not intended to
be academic exercises but a concrete
contribution to a practical debate
involving intellectuals and many terms
in the venatori stock recei bent on
reforming the venetian army on the basis
of knowledge based from the study of the
ancient Greek and Roman militia just as
Palladio has turned in in the practice
of architecture to the example of
ancient Rome as a model for constructing
buildings in his own time so - he made
available his knowledge of the
military's military orders of Caesar
Hannibal in Scipio as a source from
which to pursue
contemporary practice he did so again as
architecture without neglecting the
experience of his own age whether the
source was Machiavelli and Della Valle
text or the unfolding of the real
military campaigns on which he was kept
up-to-date by friends like Stefan and
Iran oh this is very well drawing of the
Lisbon area during the siege of 1580
sent by Stefan guarana the son of
Giacomo dedicated the quattro libri to
Palladio in July 1518 in which is the
diplomacy job defending the dominions
and cities is what is most important in
his preface to the commentaries Palladio
does reveals a civil commitment driving
his interests in warfare for lumbus
distil birthday this is one of the
architects major duties
Palladio may have read alberta striking
words on the subject in his preface to
the dara a difficult area I quote from
Albert II and Albert he said and if you
were to examine the expedition that have
been undertaken you might well find that
the most victories were one more through
the art and skills of the architects
then through the conduct or fortune of
the commanders and that the enemy was
more often overcome and conquered by the
architects weight without the
commander's arm then by commanders armed
without the artists weight and what is
of great importance is that the
architects conquest with a few men and
without the loss of jobs I think that
Palladio was interested in warfare also
for another reason
he was born in 1580 in the midst of the
Wars of Padua which had been lost and
warned back by the Venetians with a
heavy blood toll for the bad ones in the
tragic son of 15:9 little Andrea must
have experienced the war from
low among the frightened starving
ordinary people hence his first memories
was probably linked with the years of
fear war and siege in the following in
the following years at the dinner table
of trissino in his humanistic soldiers
Palladio and ready Pietro became Toledo
was to see war from another point of
view but a document I discovered in the
vicen archive during the preparation
for the palazzo exhibition 2008 leave us
little doubt regarding Pelagius opinion
on war it is a testimony during a court
case offered by a friend of Bellagio the
painter Giovanni Battista McGrath began
sir it is a testimony of the vain
attempt of magan's and Palazzo to this
way their friend Marco DNA from seeking
glory on the battlefield McGann's
recalled is finished fortunately I can't
understand exactly Roberto but began
cervical one evening a few days before
the sacred Marco went to war
I was with Palazzo in the house of the
splendid chain and in our conversation
with Lord Marco we came to the subject
of his decision to go to the wall Paulo
doing trial and I tried to persuade him
as best we could that he should not go
reminded him that is was most dangerous
on account of this Lord Marco became
angry with us because he said he wished
to go and he seemed to be offended by
all our attempts to dissuade him then
count
Francesco Marc Marco Diaz uncle computer
arrived and on hearing our discussion
say said the count Marco this words this
men meaning Palladio and myself count
Marco our true friends they give you
good advice advice with Marco DNA did
not act upon and which caused him
life he was taken out by a crusade
during a real war and not a war on paper
during the month war campaigns thank you
very much
in 1973 a young scholar by the name of
Howard burns published his first
significant work with an illustration
wasn't quite this one but it was related
to this one the temple of Assisi a
version of this you can see in the
Morgan and he made a kind of fantastic
proposition which is that what was
important to Pilate oh here was the
collapse in two dimensions of the three
dimensional circumstance and that would
lead to that same kind of collapse to
come to palazzo valmarana
in other words and let's remember that
this was 1973 the same year that Peter
iseman published his first significant
essay on Tehran yay and also common row
and Roberts Leslie published their text
on second part of transparency it was a
kind of miss reading on Pilate as part
that the Renaissance was not necessarily
about truth was about Renaissance inton
as every Renaissance historian is said
to me from guido to Howard and that it
is this radical miss reading of the
drawing that creates a new kind of
architecture this kind of radical miss
reading of a drawing is the kind of
thing that you would expect to happen
sometime in the 70s or 80s by I don't
know a kind of architect like Peter
Eisenman it's not by the way even though
Pilate Oh had visited Rome in many times
but particularly the last time in 1554
and seen the first two Bay's of
Michelangelo's giant order in the comodo
show it's not at all like that it's not
merely
residing on the surface of the Palazzo
it actually digs in he digs in so much
that it breaks that middle and tablature
cutting right into it in a way and this
is one of four abuses that Palladio does
the structure in this building he has a
chapter chapter 22 on abuses in the
Quattro Libre where he says okay after
all we're not really doing structure but
at least we have to represent something
that looks like real structure in order
not to frighten our viewers over here
but there are four times in this
building where he actually breaks the
structure abuses the structure certainly
one of them is the fact of breaking this
and tablature another one is cutting
into the entablature on the top one over
here and then there's an oh snap moment
if we in fact we take away the column in
the giant order and we see how we can
now return the entablature in the middle
but sure and leaving the two half
plasters or if we want to look at a
drawing that Palladio did of a roman
theater in verona and see a similar
series of three layers over here with a
single column we can go ahead and put a
single column in there we can take it
out but that's the way the building is
in other words Howard Burns had
suggested there was an outside in that
there was a way of bringing in bringing
in an outside series of columns pressing
them into the surface and now we're
going to look at Palladio inside out
this drawing to me is the rosetta stone
of this series of studies that I've been
doing thanks to you know having said
that plots of a Marana and the loggia
ducati on over to
buildings that were had never really no
one had ever really cracked the code of
and he had seen some of my digital
analysis of Julie Romano and thought
that these might to help crack the code
this drawing is a Code Breaker for me it
is a drawing that Palladio did where he
took the inside which is the courtyard
view and brought it flat to the outside
Palladio uses his split screen effect
many times in the cuatro libro sometimes
in a complete drawing as in this villa
rotunda and template piece but he also
and this is quite different in fact from
what I want to call the carving to the
pumpkin views that you find in the melon
Codex in the Morrigan or in the Codex
Cana where you're carving in and you're
supposed to see some kind of perspective
a condition claudia isn't the first i
would like to say was the first but i
actually prefer to say that it's julie
Romano who's the first who does a full
split screen where you have the
elevation on one side and in orthogonal
view of the interior and the other side
we know from from you know about
romanian Howard burns how crucial Giulio
Ramona was to Pilate oh not only in
handing off of Palazzo 10a but also in
the parametric flexing of the sewer
Liana or where I want to call an
arcuated lintel that happened not only
the Basilica but as guido Bob jhemini
has pointed out with reference to San
Benedetto Poe from Julie Romano and
that's also true you can see that in the
inside over here but even this back part
and the back part of the Basilica where
you have that arcuated lintel but
Palladio is the only one at least until
we rediscover
missing drawings of Giulio Romano that
actually used in a more systematic way
this flip screen throughout Quattro
Libre you have these facing pages which
show the outside and the inside of his
reconstructions let's be clear this is a
fantasy of Pilate owes over here he is
not he's drawn based on ruins and
imagining in his own image what this
might be like if we go ahead and put
that together we can begin to see that
what Claudio does is not ongoing outside
in but inside out and he's breaking down
the various layers of the building and
drawing them all to one flat plane and
the animation that looks like something
like this
and now if we were to compare the
elements in Pilates reconstruction of
the temple of Nerva Trajan with some of
the elements in plots of our Marana you
see the giant order columns appear you
see the middle scale columns appear
the smaller scale
related also to the archway the figures
at the top the top and tablature
the middle entablature with this
associated figure
in the bottom pedestal and continuous
bass
in other words I would claim that these
two drawings from Quattro libro that you
have Palladio miss reading his own
reconstructions in order to imagine a
new construction of what our Palazzo
would be you can see this in the side
view also where you see those elements
again
the large columns the middle columns the
figures the pedestals and then the
entablatures and here you can see quite
clearly that it's a strange miss reading
of just what is visible between those
columns and how that entablature in the
courtyard is split which relates to
similarly with the temple of Antonius
and Faustina same sort of principles
Network and thus we come to miss rosetta
stone of his drawing here and if we look
to see at the courtyard and we noticed
particularly these strange extensions of
the entablature over here in the frieze
area these beam ends and we see what
that drawing where that drawing was
supposed to be might have been all the
way back in the intended court that was
never built more likely it was embedded
and cut through here facing that way but
that's collapsed to the surface
and now we can begin to see how inside
comes out and starts to influence the
outside so you see the courtyard columns
middle scale columns and the middle
scale columns on the facade the beam
ends over here and the trace of that on
the end column
we went a half columns at the end making
the one and a half columns over here
that one and a half becoming the
dimension of the courtyard column
and there you see strange demons and the
projection of the entablature at the end
where the time order is removed another
way to imagine this outside this inside
out is to look at an earlier instead of
the 1570 Quattro libri to look at his
first drawings for the Vitruvius
the addition of a true vias of Barbara
produced and what you have here is in
the way in which the image starts to
bleed through from the other side of the
paper you can begin to see what every
architect with a roll of trace paper
notices which is that there are a co
incidence of images that one then might
miss read and build upon that's what's
on the backside the interior view of
this Roman house reconstruction again a
figment of Pilate o--'s imagination and
we now can see what would happen if we
animate this and let the ink really
bleed through
and you can begin to see how that bleed
through begins to resemble valmarana
quite a bit over here you have the
doorway appearing between the giant
order you have the balustrade and the
window you have an archway you have
these middle scale columns here this
drawing which looks like it was in the
same series for Palladio or bringing the
outside court to the the inside court to
the outside of palazzo Porto is in fact
not by Palladio it is a later
combination by John William Talman in
the late 17th early 18th century over
here they cut two drawings and put them
together perhaps because they had indigo
Jones drawings perhaps in the spirit of
the valmarana drawing but nevertheless
it points out to an important moment in
the social history for Pilate over here
of conceiving what a Palazzo and a villa
and what the recombination of antiquity
in the present might mean for the social
classes as Pilate oh did his experiments
in the in the Reformation of villas and
Palacios his character as Peter will
show us later on and all these mutations
of these giant orders and porches and
Palazzo types we combining of course the
the Palazzo over here of Bramante
palazzo capri knee with its clear
division of a rusticated base and the
noble floor the piano nobile a various
versions of that by Raphael with the
assistance of Julie Romano and then
Giulio Romano and Palazzo Maharani
starting to now blend starting to create
a much more hybrid condition between
these surfaces but here you have Pilate
arrow here now bringing the giant
order all the way through this base
condition here's that oh snap moment
where what happened I mean really it
should be like this what happened to the
support particularly at the end where
you need to support the most in order to
have a stable idea of what we imagine
the Renaissance to be but in reality
that's what did we could look for the
the ideas behind these modalities in
some of Pilate OHS patrons in Barbara
himself and the issues of humanism and
and performative nests of of rhetoric
and other arts we can look at racino and
he is recombination of even the alphabet
where he adds Greek letters to the Roman
alphabet Latin alphabet and or - as his
own recombination of Greek themes in the
play and the epic poem that Guido
mentioned over here that would be the
second degree of separation and it's a
crucial work to be done but not in today
today's lecture but we can certainly now
with reference superfast reference to
Julia's work oh right - the modalities
of Pilate Oh in this fantastic work that
the Guido has been doing where what you
have is these tactical maneuvers and
what I would claim is that Palladio is
involved in tactical tectonic maneuvers
tactical tactical spatial maneuvers
tactical social maneuvers of of class
and culture in the final example this is
Pilate Oh turns a corner Pilate of turns
a corner inside out really you have this
very strange like building the loggia de
cavity on Oh
no one has ever really explained why you
suddenly get this collapse of scale on
the side over here it's quite an odd
building but if we take the valmarana
drawing and that was the revelation for
me that we could now unfold the two
elevations it would be like the
valmarana drawing we can start to now
compare the survey drawings of them Iran
and loggia and now unfold them it looks
something like this there is a precedent
for this in Pilate himself his drawing
for the Ark of Gavi and Verona right
next to scarves Casa de Vecchio where he
took the site elevation and pasted it on
to the front elevation in fact in Falmer
Ana the very pedestal this curving
strange unusual curving pedestal is also
from Arana and we can even create the
loggia out of the taking the drawing and
using the survey drawings to recreate
that and if we get it closer to the
loggia at another column on the other
side of the archway and the very same
comparison in cuatro libro over here
where we see similar elements we have
the giant order columns we have the
middle scale columns we have the
inclining figures and we have the
entablatures going through and similarly
with that second form with their kind of
trace conditions over here a principle
that Peter Osmond has often talked about
in his Mis readings over here we again
have similar traces of these elements
coming through in the loggia and if this
is not a tactical maneuver I don't know
what is the way
the door frame and the balustrade in the
archway can line up to this strange
drawing on the bath of Agrippa were
Pilate Oh illustrates what he'll do
DeLozier quickly going through the
corners and the edges for Pilate over
here which all going to skip through
over here now will notice that plots of
em are on and the loggia and in this
this interesting ragged edge over here
but Palladio knew how to make an edge in
a sarcophagus and arch of travertine he
always made a appropriate extension at
the edge in order to be able through the
Capitol to have a background in the
rialto bridge and the alternative
interest of the bridge of Rialto that
really showed us over here you can see
it over here two times the side to cover
the Capitol that's what the Lozier would
look like if Pilate oh did that who
that's what in fact it looks like that's
what it would look like if in fact a lot
of you had done that but that's in fact
this collapse along the edge and we
could begin to see now the way in and as
he turns the corner the way the base
elements now start to recombinator
mutate the base the arches into an
arcuated lintel the single balconies
into this mutant balcony and so on the
base direction
you can see that that whole mutation
along that four piece you can see when
it comes around the corner how strange
it is the way it cuts in a brutal way
that capital over there the way this
silver iana breaks through the
entablature quite brutal there's that
strange moment the collapse of that side
already and as Archer already we're
turning the corner for Pilate Oh Pilate
was turn the corner of his work and
starting to involve in his most complex
late work of the churches and in this
detail in the sanma George a drawing
over here cinema giorgio maggiore
drawing over here we can start to see
the relation between these two elements
that looks like this in animation
you're the two versions you oversee
mutation of
now if we bring in the loggia flip it
clone the detail
you can start to witness the mutation
and that's to conclude we can see that
now in the unfolded drawing the whole
mutation of different scale of elements
and niches and windows and giant orders
and small orders start to happen between
the loggia and the first church San
Francesco which you see here or in San
Jorge oh and you start to see the
strange way in which now the nervous
energy of the Venetian environment the
Venetian wall surface starts to become a
whole mutant internal surface with this
total train wreck of a series of columns
and plasters and the corner over here
this mutant corner and you read and
tour where you have the similar form of
mutation you have in fact Palladio now
coming from his travels to Rome from
just wrapping up here travels from Rome
experiencing the mannerism of Vermont
and Raphael and jus Romano meeting that
nervous service but but as individual
elements and now meeting that nervous
surface treatment in Venice and
recombining both of them into these
nervous forms over here in this model
which I will leave you with if you
squint at it enough to see this mutant
form of colonnade in the church over
here you might you might look like some
of the drawings you saw under student
publication abstract that you picked up
last week over here but you can
certainly take a look at it in the
morgue and where it resides now thank
you
he drives I was told we're gonna watch
the final four tonight and I don't know
if we're gonna get to do that but all of
you don't care much about basketball so
he wouldn't be here
thank you
I'm going to talk about the Palazzo
karakov II I'm going to show a few
drawings basically my thesis I have made
about 800 drawings of palacios buildings
as Mark would tell you I I tend to miss
read what I'm reading so therefore I'm
not sure it's Pilate or me that I'm
drawing but doesn't matter it's a way of
looking at the work I want to suggest
that that I believe that all
architecture is coded and Mark raised
that issue that there are no agreed-upon
sign systems that you can look at things
as as Guido did or mark did in one way
or another way you can see battle
formations you can see mutations you can
see whatever you want to see and I
actually believe that's true and how do
I get the first slide
this is the corner of the Palazzo
Deucalion orbino and the reason why I
showed you I think is a an idea of a
formal resolution to a a corner where
you can see the doubling of the columns
the flattening of the columns and you
clearly read corner and and on to the
next one this is Bramante's Santa Maria
del Apache and the solution at the
corner is a very strange one its first
of all a very strange courtyard because
it's a for opening courtyard and there
very few with a column in the center
which is a no-no and in all of the books
of history that we know about that
basically I would call this a a virtual
court in the sense that Bramante had a
pre-existing scheme it didn't fit into
the site and therefore you get the
strange conditions of of a corner where
we have this rosette left over from
columns so that I think that they're
very different the courtyard and orbino
is a formal resolution and the courtyard
in the Santa Maria de la pocha refers to
something I would call as a virtual
organization that is it speaks to
something that isn't there that can't be
known from what is there but speaks of
another kind of organization here is vid
covers view of Palladio of course for me
I've always found a problem with this
but it takes away one of the most
important elements of Palladian work and
that is the poche
thickness of the walls and how you can
tell the difference between Pilate
evangelist Komachi and others through
the application of the po che how you
can tell the difference between inside
and outside through po che but here vid
cover reduces Pilate Oh to a mere set of
line drawings Chiara copy is interesting
to me because I assume that there is a
virtual Villa not an ideal Villa but a
virtual villa that exists in Palladian
work a virtual schemata which starts
from an a b c ba from front to back that
is an a is a portico a b is a transition
space a c is a maiden space usually
articulated by po che a B is the rear
circulation space and a is the final
portico and here we have all of those
elements in a virtual villa compressed
into a series of layers and you have to
notice the portico here where this
double column tells you that in fact
there is a compression of a portico
element which is the a element into the
transition space or the B element so you
have a over B you have the C which is
the the main space always articulated by
poche and we could go through hundreds
of drawings that would show the the
state of this virtual villa and then we
have what is the most amazing thing is
the compression of the rear portico into
the B or circulation space so the a is
compressed into the B to give you a
garden back here and what you get is
for me one of the most fantastic of the
villas if you read it in terms of this
virtual villa of a compressed series of
layers unlike any of the other villas
there's bertoni's Komatsu's rendition of
the same project and you can see just in
the drawing how Claudia loses the the
sex of the poche and its reduced to a
very limited palette of drawing
Bellavia zone drawing of key riccati and
what I did was to try and describe
through a series of acts and the metrics
which I won't bore you with but a series
of diagrams which try and and elaborate
this overlay so that the the blue is
always the C space the pink and other
colors are the a and B spaces and the
drawings attempt each one of them to
show a different aspect of the
compression of this virtual villa that
is the the elements are there their
syntax their formal syntax is is very
different than they would be in the
virtual ABC be a rendition but they're
all still there a further compression of
these and you see the little arrows
pointing to those compressions that
sometimes work from the front
sometimes operate from the back the
ancillary spaces here and here in the
blue of the sea organization and again a
variation of that in terms of the po che
and then another reading of the blue
or main space again with this
compression acting upon the diagram
these drawings were picked out of a of a
sequence of about I guess they're about
80 or 90 on the palazzo Terra Cotta that
I made to try and understand every bit
of the poche and what exists in the
actual building and here we get the
compression of the portico into the B or
what I call gasket space the circulation
space and then the compression of this
into the sea or central space and an
overlay then of the columns they operate
in these two spaces and then flattening
out into what would be a normal a b c b
a and you can see how there is the
compression of the all of those elements
into this flattened rendition of a
virtual villa
there you can see very clearly the
letters ABC ba which would be the actual
layers as they would appear this layer
is outboard of the portico that's
compressed this layer is behind the wall
of the garden and you see how this would
be the layers of this virtual villa and
how they then become compressed as the a
over B and they over B in the rear and
the C being the only space left as it
were intact and then again the C space
being acted upon from both the front and
rear causing what would be normally a
oval or more circular space to be a
compressed lozenge shape and one sees it
in that there see this I feel for me is
a very useful exercise because I can
then take and read all of the Palladian
villas with this same kind of diagnostic
to show that they can be read in any
number of ways and and and to show in
fact that there are a lot of issues in
Palladio that have something to do with
the space that we operate in today I
want to thank Mark for allowing me to
show these images in the context of a
very serious discussion they are
interesting and illuminating too
but probably very little to do with the
historiography of Pilate oh and I also
want to say that for 50 years since the
first time that I went to see the loggia
I found out that I had been spelling it
and pronouncing it wrong I was told it
was the Logitech Capitano and now I find
out it's the low Judah copy tomahto and
I never heard that before in my life
so for 50 years I've been under the miss
miss illusion that I was looking at
something in I now have to correct my
own illusion thank you very much
um I have a couple of quick questions
but really I want to let see if if these
gentlemen have questions for each other
among the questions I want to ask Peter
didn't you didn't really spell out let's
say Y out of any of the villas you
wanted to obsess about karakov t it
isn't a natural choice among his among
his buildings why that Palazzo and and I
think it would be worthwhile cuz clearly
it's been obsessing you by the number of
germs you've been doing why you think it
has to do with practice today and well
first of all if modernist base is to be
seen as well if we start with an
assumption that I make as an architect
not as a as a scholar that the
difference between Greek and Roman space
is that Greek space going back to the
time when they moved from wood to stone
demands a being seen on the 45-degree
angle that you have to understand the
Parthenon and
neoclassical buildings are always drawn
Schinkel from the from the corner
receding into a kind of space and roman
space is thought to be frontal and and
in fact layered and I would argue that
the difference for me between in modern
architecture between Greek and Roman is
between me and the Corbusier Mesa is
always meant to be seen on the on the
corner as is Philip Johnson's glass
house and Corbeau is meant to be seen
like garish and glossy and nasone cook
and and many others frontally so that
modern space for me modernist base is
layered flattened cubist space etc and
when you go in 1960 as a neophyte to see
lots of Karikari
you say oh my gosh that's that's
flattened modernist space very unlike
rotunda which I find another one of the
least interesting of the villas because
it has you know it does have its own
flattening and its own layering but
probably in a very much more subtle way
and so karikari always struck me as as
really important as
can you know talking about the
possibility of layered space in the
sixteenth century and of course when I
went with row to see these things Colin
would would say he'd go sit in the pub
someplace and have a you know beer or
whatever and I was to sit in the Sun and
and analyze what it was that I saw in
each of the villas that couldn't be seen
that is that was not there and of course
the one that was the most difficult for
me and remains the most difficult and
problematic is Keira Conti and of course
trying to describe what isn't there is a
continual preoccupation of mine in the
drawings that I make
and the lesson of Roe for me was always
and I remember spending many many hours
the Venetian son seeing what wasn't
there
and that's why I think Palacio is
important and I think that's why Carole
coddies is important and that's why I
think it's important to consider space
today final question about that and then
I want to ask questions to both you
gentlemen over here and then open it up
to the audience well to see if you have
questions first for each other and then
open it up it seemed to me that in spite
of the fact that at various points Rose
suggested that what would happen in
literal in in in phenomenological
transparency which that the incidence of
what you couldn't see would find their
way to the facade in fact most of time
it was a collapse on the facade for him
and not this internal movement you
almost immediately or at least by well
even in your thesis started to look at
something that he wasn't looking at
which is that internal movement coming
out and
outside movement coming in no my thesis
was written as an attempt to get out
from under row as I've said on many
occasions I mean the the row influence
having done it for 90 days and 90 nights
for two summers without a break I got it
alright I got it as badly as anybody and
I needed to find a way out and the
thesis was actually an attempt to
critique row & pratik rows from you of
especially of coreboot irani and and
Palladio and and by introducing first of
all the whole idea of inside outside and
the second probably even more
importantly the first introduction of
the linguistic paradigm let's say and of
course Rho couldn't stand anything that
resembled linguistics or what he would
consider science or pseudoscience and so
this was my writing this was my attempt
to rethink and reform what I had learned
from Rho I'm gonna get to my final
general question for you to but I'll
throw it back to you Peter and then turn
to Guido which is but in thesis even
though you Illustrated karakov T you
illustrated as I can remember the exact
words but these were stable units when
did you start seeing kara coffee as with
the
more dynamical conditions that you are
now illustrating now in other words you
didn't put it under the analysis you put
the other buildings in that eye harder
to reconstruct when I started to relook
at a lot of these things that I talked
about in the thesis don't forget if you
were to read what I wrote about the
tehrany and you read about what's in my
book they're very different texts if you
read about what I wrote about the
Corbusier and what I've written
subsequently you would find it's very
different so you have to understand that
1963 a very naive American was writing
some very naive stuff about things that
were three and four years before Rossi
venturi pragati or any of those people
240 had published anything I was writing
in the dark basically in a sense in a
Dark Age writing about something that
very few people had very much interested
so I can be forgiven I think some
alterations to what I thought in 62 63
and what I thought let's say starting in
73 when I started rethinking very
clearly those projects we dohe in the
frontispiece that you showed us for
Caesar
that we're after the blah blah blah and
it said illustrated illustrations by
Palladio and it's and I can remember
your you were translation but you know
for the purpose and I remember the words
on the frontispiece of the cognition of
history to help with the cognition of
history what do you think the role how
would you like to refer to the role of
Palladio or architects as illustrators
of history thinking out loud to
facilitate the readers understanding of
history but the word that's used is
cognition so cognition yeah who needs
Sione yes what's the I mean given
readings and mis readings constructions
and reconstructions and mystery
constructions that Palladio engaged in
and the play between the two what would
you say would be his role as someone who
brings forth history as thinking as
cognition
I try to understand if Palladio so a to
reconstruct the cities for instance I
try to understand the sources of
Palladio if he use if he uses Maps or
other things and I understood that
Palladio doesn't use anything only
starts from the previous words and as in
through this book you have to start from
the words of the book and if you look at
the buildings in informations like
vargas city of papers
design space battles only on the basis
of words and this is his way of history
we must remember that also Caesar and
poor abuse firsthand sources because
Caesar talking about his battles and
Polybius was testimony witness of the
battles and police say they try to see
all the place all the battles of animals
and I also spoke with person who was
there when anybody questions for each
other
desire to move on was the the drawings
really speak to what I would call
positional and relational notations
rather than proportional or functional
in other words they are merely reading
away the formal conditions of proportion
ratio function to use etc and what I
wanted to show is that you could read
Palladio in an entirely different way
that is in its positional and that's why
I say it's not an ideal Villa it's a
it's a virtual positioning of an a space
of B space CBA and then every one of and
even in the churches I can do it with
Regan Torre and Maggiore I can I can
produce a positional and relational
notation that begins to see these
buildings in an entirely different way
than reading the proportional or their
functional use and that was the
intention is to try and develop a
topology
of of relations and positions rather
than proportions only to say that parts
of Calicut is really the the most
important building fort ilandia because
is the turning point of his career
before Pilate kellicotti
Pilate was another man and Palazzo
kellicotti is hidden by his new language
completely different from everything so
you obviously chose exactly
I think the navel because if you wait
per Otsuki riccati Pilate became if we
might assume that Peter has opposing the
proportioning opposing vid Cofer in the
question of proportioning not unlike his
mentor Colin Rowe who was in flight from
Vic over even as he used but in fact if
positioning is would be otherwise seen
as a kind of miss reading precisely what
we saw from you Guido today is that
positioning and repositioning is an
obsession
questions from the audience
from paper secondly this mr. Esmond in
saying he's entitled to reconsider what
he wrote 40 years ago again Palladio in
1570 of the four books it goes back to
his early projects and redesigns that so
we engineers them in the light of
experience and his didactic purpose in
producing the book but just reverting to
the practice okey riccati what
fascinates me about the way you
described the the ABCB a process is that
philosophy art he mixes up spaces in a
way that he doesn't anywhere else
because the a the portico is a public
space it's the Hyatt the highly visible
space and it's of the space that the
homeless visitor would reach the be in
the villas is a private space and yet in
the plastic area coffee because of the
situation of the palace overlooking a
public square and the deal that cleric
RT does with the city authorities to
gain extra space for his villa because
it his palace because it's on a very
narrow strip and he he negotiated with
the City Council to get extra space
providing the ground floor was given
over to public walkway and he could
build his rooms over the top gives a
completely different faith I just wonder
if you have any views on how bloody I
saw his face is being used
well honestly I'm not anthropologists or
sociologists I'm really totally
unconcerned with how they were used I'm
interested in the formal for example the
loggia I've had explained to me the
loggia that I called Capitano which is
not that
okay anyway when you see that corner I
touch so reverently with my students
last fall it was explained to me why
that side was a smaller scale why the
the function in the Civic functions had
something to do with why the front or
what we call the front was a larger
scale and this was a smaller scale I
can't even remember what that is all I
can remember is that corner is something
I say to my students hey see that that's
architecture and take a look at it I
don't know how to explain it any better
I don't believe whether they could tell
me what the function was would help them
explain how to make that architecture
because there's something magical that
that corner for me is is one of the
great corners in architecture and I know
there's a functional reason for it to be
that way but nevertheless the the magic
is still
the most important thing for historians
for scholars they need to explain in a
different way I need to teach my kids
who I teach how to see that corner not
to know why it was that way
I also don't know if it is a question or
maybe a comment also in relationship to
carry kotti which i think you know one
of the first thing that I would mention
is that it's not included in the covers
dire right and that is to me a little
bit of a key the reason that is not part
of the idea of villas right may be a key
to understand another kind of problem
which is something that maybe we cover
was looking for extreme sort of
relationship across these villas that
were quite similar to each other
understanding a problem variation of
maybe mark put it in his presentation
and I wonder you know what something
that is very interesting in key riccati
that that variation inquires such a
change right the still can real a nine
square grid in the Palazzo ki khatti but
it's extremely reform right and that
extreme deformation what it does to me
at least right
Italy criticizes the entire typological
question that we cover somehow trace
across the entire Levitas so I think
that in that sense pushed together a
certain interesting relationship between
topology as a certain kind of relative
deformation or gradual deformation
against a rather more structural
deformation or maybe a type so I wonder
you know if in that sense the
interesting on the layering right what
it produces to the 9 square grid is such
carry such a radical transformation of
the type and why doesn't that was
included maybe in the colors diagrams
but he doesn't include the
with their villas include lots of
would you say that that's nice and
square for sure and how would you say it
have been well I've tried to show I mean
you could argue that hard to do with
that yeah it's it's it is a compression
of a nine square critters as most of the
villas are even though there are five
part relates you what's interesting is
is there are five part relationship from
side to side and front to back and yet
which is would give you twenty five
squares yes see that's what I mean it's
not it's not it's not really it is it is
actually both nine and twenty five yeah
which is a variation it's not four and
16 right so you know but also it's
interesting that typological because
isn't exactly telling the truth when he
says he's not really interested in use
because the very description of a B and
C were all youths descriptions their
descriptions of privates their
descriptions of what those
I mean that they you have to say portico
I mean you know I don't know no no but
you were you're talking about the
ceremonial space in the middle and which
is the projets space I could say shave
space the C space is always the
post-chaise space okay
this base with the the articulate poche
yeah which has of sucks reviews which
has a social yes the po che ya know the
fact the fact of it the fact that it is
pochette yeah yeah but the social use
I'm not really interested in I'm
interested in the fact that it is the PO
shade space and Vick over leaves that
you referring to terracotta you're
trying to
but one thing to say about the caracal
aside is that was completely different
in the sixteenth century because is
really an open space because that was
the edge of the city in front of our
akatsuki riccati was completely empty
because was the Arbor of the four ball
tonight and so was really in a very
unusual position because he's at the
edge of the city not inside the city
completely empty in front of him and
from the lodges of upstairs you can see
all the all the countryside and so is is
really a strange object because it's not
a it's not a palace because you can see
from afar you are not compressed like
but also others and you can see from the
palace very far and also this is
completely unusual name for a baby
I wanted to say that one of the things
that vid cover leaves out which I think
is extraordinary is that what would we
would call the bar Casa the outbuildings
which poll Ivo included in his drawings
in most of his projects and the
outbuildings are really what tie these
structures to the land and so you can
say well not only are there no
orientation but there's no tie to the
site
and not to have the bar Casa and to have
students sing these this is the way
these things were are really false I
mean I think it was a a real mutation
that that vid cover did for his own
purposes and whereas to me one of the
important issues is the bar Casa and how
they relate and how they related to the
whole project of of entry and
organization of project of Pilates to
connect the house with the other case
yes this is the new because also before
colada you can find farm in the
countryside with a threshing floor with
columbaria with together and create an
architecture and this is true I think
this is the problem
I think the
I was wondering in the course of looking
at the three presentations I couldn't
help it of course to look at the three
presentations I couldn't help but
receive a sort of research transition
and any distinction between the
operation of let's say moving from solid
to void that is to say I was instructed
particular from the opening sequence
when we saw some articles and we saw the
distinction in terms of cinematography
of looking frontally almost four
thousand three as you say looking at the
marching of roman columns always from a
distance so that we really perceived a
greater aggregated geometries as opposed
to the closer preferred lovers so the
distinction that sit between the lambda
single soldier as opposed to the greater
aggregate of the soldiers so that we
comprise it with a large geometry I was
wondering in that case because I
couldn't help but sort of perceive a
distinction in terms of the presentation
work the first one we saw something that
was much more analysis in plan which
transitions later in much more analysis
in elevation and then later into a
medicine axonometric in a sense at the
same time I saw the distinction moving
from the operation of let's say if we
wanted to bring by the theme of this
conference census data genome moving
from combination to recombination such
that we have a piece of lambda which
originally starts our implant as an
anonymous piece of brick let's say the
same way that we have the lambda
associated with a factor a person was
operationally entirely indistinctly
different such that they only comprise
more pieces of large geometry and
they're transitioning from this stone
and say the solid material into the
elevation to cardinality oh and then
later as no metric into the void the
spaces so that is a distinction between
the void and solarek operation even
though at the same time the capacity of
operating on this sort of solid avoid
mass this lambda is contained throughout
so I was wondering if we could sort of
address this notion that I just couldn't
help but receive because of looking at
your convenience rather perhaps a
intentional presentations I'm gonna try
to summarize that what I understand
Michael your question was the the
different relations of solid and void
when you start from the plan let's say
Birds I plan and bird's eye view in
Guido's presentation the not exclusively
facade but more just following your
lines vertical facade orientation in
mine and then Peters X honor metric I
said is that accurate
I am these two gentlemen are asked me to
summarize here
let me ask this Michael because we're
it's getting a little Blaine we've got a
couple more questions over here which
we'll do quickly that that could stand
as a as a as a statement I'm more than a
question I mean a form of analysis that
tried to link to three papers which I
which I makes you know it's food for
thought for all of us about those
relations that you've mentioned over
here but do you have a person you want
to like pitch it at somebody over here
I I'm getting nervousness on the side
over here because this this basketball
player over here is I I think residents
watching I I think I think that's a
really crucial question but I I think
that that after a few more we should
take that up so it's a long answer I
think it would be a different answer for
each of us but I think it's a it's a
very interesting question about how you
how you perceive the unit and from where
and how it would reposition to use that
in relation to these questions of void
and shift as you're bringing you know I
think that's a crucial question for all
of us for sure I'm just gonna take a
couple more questions so Frederic yeah
you mentioned that you were looking for
this inside and I think we know your
desire for looking for pleasure of the
mind that is built within the
environment and do you think that
fellatio through a strategy of
compression and an inscription of maybe
those two military men or those form
that were frozen in stone but existed in
multiple possible reading on the people
level was also trying to
I never try to second-guess an architect
you know I never I don't know what
Corbeau was up to or me sir
you know or tehrani I mean you know I
don't try and do that I just say I look
at the stuff and I say hey here's what I
do
I mean Jacques Derrida oh when I worked
with him used to say hey you don't need
me because you miss read everything and
I do
and so miss reading is what
deconstruction is all about so it
doesn't matter to me whether Pilate a
very firm head shape from from Benjamin
who has to get us off to the restaurant
and so I want to thank Benjamin I also
want to thank a couple people in the
audience over here who helped produce
some of the remarkable drawings over
here in my presentation Luke Wilson
Michael Young Benjamin Hobart and gamja
Kim over here and I'd like to thank
these two gentlemen over here Guido and
and now Murray of the RBA for holding on
to these precious